all right so let's talk for a second
about the Dragon Ball Fighter's English
translation because it's pretty bad back
in the day English translations of anime
and anime games used to alter Lions
character names and so on to quote
better suit the Western audience but
nowadays that's pretty much gone to the
waight side or at least except for
Fighters half the lions in this game
story mode are completely totally
Rewritten not just like different
interpretations of the same line but I
mean like ignore the original line and
make up your own because funny like take
this for example where Yamcha is praying
to quote God for the enemy to not be too
strong and Piccolo retorts with a sick
roast except that's not what he says at
all in the Japanese Yamcha is indeed
praying to God for the opponent to be
weak but Piccolo replies with you do
know dende is God right it's literally
align from the manga and this stuff is
all over the place in Fighters and the
worst part is you literally can't even
buy Fighters Japanese version on PC disc
only baby